Premiere beim chaoskochen Summer Jam ich
glaube es war das erste Mal für ihn in
einer Küche er wird eine Menge lernen
und das ist sehr spaig und spaig ist
auch das was wir kochen nämlich suschuk
und champagna heißt sein neues Album was
kochen wir natürlich ein Rezept mit
sutschuk und Champagner ob das passt
seht ihr jetzt beim
chaoskochen meine sehr vererehrten Damen
und her herzlich willkommen beim
chaoskochen mit niemand geringerem als
Summerjam der sich in ungewohnte Gefühle
begeben hat richtig auf jeden Fall das
ist eine Weltpremiere
normalerweise aus meinem kulturellen
Kreis wo ich herkomme ist es streng
verboten für mich in die Küche zu gehen
der christoph hat jetzt wirklich darauf
bestanden deshalb werde ich versuchen
mich so gut wie möglich mit
irgendwie da mitzuhelfen aber wir
schauen mal was ich alles auf die Re
Kriege okay pass auf ich glaube daran
bist du Experte weil wir kochen heute
ein Rezept von demx 90
suschuk
und Erdbeeren okay Kartoffeln habe ich
noch dazu genommen so und er möchte dass
wir dazu eine Soße machen aus
handelsüblichen Apfelmus und jetzt pass
auf damit passt nämlich perfekt zu
deinem neuen Album natürlich Champagne
genau Champagner so jetzt würde ich
sagen du kümmerst dich mal um die
sutchuk dass wir die so in irgendwelche
Teile teilen dass man sie in die Pfanne
tun kann dafür haben wir ich weiß nicht
ob du das kennst das ist ein
Küchenmesser du kennst ja nur die die
man am Tisch benüt ein Küchenmesser
damit kann man die suschu perfekt
schneiden okay diese Art von Messer
kenne ich natürlich nicht mal die
bisschen breiteren oh Gott gut meine
Mutter wird sich jetzt auch denken warum
habe ich einen Sohn auf die Welt
gebracht wenn der dann in der Küche
landet ich mach das jetzt so bisschen
auf choban Art ich kannte das ja vorher
noch nicht das ist eine was ist das für
eine Wurst rinderwurst okay
ich mach jetzt wirklich auf mal
Style irgendwie so vileich Scheiben oder
so dass man braten kann so oder ne so
will ich machen ich widme mich der WE
mal den Kartoffeln wir haben auch eine
Kamera sensationell wenn du nicht kochst
ja wie kommst du an dein Essen ich habe
eine super liebe Mama ich habe
auch super liebe Kreditkarte was kocht
die für dich eigentlich was
Gutes ich bin eigentlich Fan von Küche
okay und natürlich von türkischer Küche
und was ist dein Lieblingsessen bei
deiner Mama wo du es gerade angesprochen
hast was die sehr gut kann ist die
schlickhöfte das ist so wie so Grütze
drumherum und innen drin ist
Hackfleisch und das wird so in Wasser
gekocht und das hat so eine ganz
komische also eine runde Form aber mit
spitzen Ecken also eine Teigtasche quasi
ja es ist nicht Teig ist so Gries so
pass auf ich bin jetzt auch hier mit dem
hervorragenden Schneiden der Kartoffeln
man merkt direkt dass ich das quasi
täglich mache echt nee quatsch man merkt
halt dass ich nicht täglich mache ich
okay ah Ironie musst vorh sagen Ironie
ironiealarm ironiealarm ich bin muss
vorher kurz anmelden nur ich wünsche die
Kamera hätte eine Nase und könnte mal
hier den Geruch Filmen ja pass auf das
mache ich jetzt gleich ich habe nämlich
ein fantastisches Gesicht das ist wie
geruchsfernsehen man sieht jetzt in
meinem Gesicht wie das R und schmeckt
dann gleich
auch ich muss dazu sagen ich liebe
Knoblauch kann
was fantastisch
hmer okay GL haben V Smiley die haben
einfach dein Gesicht angeguckt und
einfach danach Smiley
gemacht jetzt pass auf das ist ein eller
her toll ja richtig gut gemacht toll ne
super
oder ah super Pass auf jetzt noch mal du
bist auch so grob guck guck guck guck
mal der Leucht jetzt und jetzt kann ich
das Hochstellen Hightech so Decke drauf
Salz Salz Salz Salz Salz so
danke ich zeig dir mal wie das geht
einfach hier abdrehen ich lasse mich
herab
okay
ich bin ja blöde das geht ja
so so jetzt bra glaub ich kannst noch
ein paar Erdbeeren schnippeln jetzt
kommt
die schon mal da
rein KST elich Long Island ne mit
geheimen Mischung Alkohol okay Long
Island könen wir auch machen okayim
Album gut da muss der Titel aber passen
machen wir dann schon irgendwie oh da
ist was angebraten ne das ist ja nicht
nicht schlimm die
Soße hab ganz vergessen was muss ich
machen einfach re und
reinun apfelm kann man das überhaupt mit
sowas essen das wer wir jetzt sehen muss
man das Rühren ja gleich muss man rühren
genau das BL schon so lang habe ich
Moment
wow was für ein
Bild beim letzten Mal wo ich in der
Küche war habe ich glaube ich Crack
gekocht okay ist aber so ähnlich oder ja
und wie riecht es ich weiß es nicht
kannst nicht zu also auf jeden Fall der
Champagner passt zum
apfelmesagt
boah an irgendwas was an was das
erinnert mich an Dings an Glühwein ja
Glühwein ja absolut jetzt weiß ich wie
die Glühwein machen Glühwein ist einfach
nur Apfelmus mit
Champagner lass euch nicht verarschen
Leute genug Mut okay
gut und hast du Angst vor dem was gleich
auf uns zukommt ich habe auf jeden Fall
großen Respekt Angst ist ja eigentlich
nicht in meinem Wortschatz drin okay wir
warten jetzt auf die Kartoffeln od wir
warten auf die Kartoffeln damit die dann
gleich fertig sind sehen sehr gut aus
wie wie merkt man das denn dass das man
kann dann
einfach Messer reinstechen und wenn das
Gut durchgeht willst es mal probieren
wenn es jetzt reinstst merkst du du
stößst auf Widerstand mit Stechen
einfach ste sich aus
ne ein bisschen widerst genau und das
muss ganz butterweich reingehen was
machen wir eigentlich mit den Erdbeeren
ja die kommen jetzt da rein boah
irgendwie ja pass auf ein
Küchenmesser
boah ist nicht dein Ernst einfach mal
mit Messer da und mich noch mal testen
alles gut die sind gut h echt mal dem
Titel Chaos kochen alle Ehre gemacht da
ist glaube ich ein bisschen hier könt
noch ein paar Erdbeeren
drauf genau und dann noch da auf die
Ecke dann ist glaube
ich als Verbindung guten
Appe sag
mal
kann man essen ich ma so das ist doch
jetzt ein Dings was machst du also ich
das hier finde ich sehr
ekelhaft was hast du was hast du machst
du das nicht ne m oh Gott
also kocht es nach
überzeugt euch selber ich wür wirklich
bin eigentlich hart im nemen was sowas
betrifft aber das geht gar nicht aber
Kartoffel kan Chr sehr gut du darfst
Christoph zu mir sagen Christoph nee
Christoph ne ich sag habe ich
Christopher gesagt jetzt
sorry Gangster Esser Hammer ey boah du
bist echt hart ich habe allergrößten
Respekt vor
dir das hätte ich mir nie gedacht dass
ich mit den Respekt bei Rappern mit
Kochen erwerbe natürlich natürlich warum
nicht das heißt ich koche so hart wie
ihr rappt ungefähr ungefähr auf jeden
Fall das ist schon
grwertig das ist gekochter dis quasi
gekochter disack du bist der Gangster
Koch number one also vielen Dank an demx
90 super Rezept unbedingt an alle der
Tipp an alle der Tipp genau an alle das
ist aber bei mir immer so wenn ich Set
oder Champagner trinke da wird die Zunge
von schwer ich kann
Whisky Wodka ich kann das Bier trinken
bis Abwinken das sagen sie alle das
sagen sie alle und dann fallen sie nach
zwei Pilz Spaß guck mal dimx 90 du hast
auf jeden Fall ein Fanpaket gewonnen ich
danke dir für dieses perverse Essen ich
konnte es leider nicht probieren aber
den Christopher schmeckt den Christoph
ich bin schon wieder bei Christopher dem
Christoph schmeckt's auf jeden Fall sehr
gut und alle die das Nachkochen wollen
auf eigene Gefahr Prost bis zum nächsten
Mal wenn es wieder heißt
wettkotzen nein chaoskochen bei klicksum
i hat noch nie jemand gekotzt höchstens
F ich habe ja nicht gegessen sonst hät
wir hier auf jeden Fall KZ Parade noch
mehr Chaos beim Chaos Kochen z.B mit
kftbefehl ein gangster rapper der aber
nicht ganz so hart in der Küche zu sein
scheint eine Menge zum Ablachen gibt's
da oder auch sehr lustig Olli Bano der
premierengast wo wir was ganz
furchtbares zubereiten nämlich Bismark
Hering mit
nutellße also wenn ihr das sehen wollt
klickt das an und ansonsten bis bald bis
dann bleibt dran
ا